abone ol
Ne
haber lan
Hoşgeldiniz bu kadar büyüklük alıp
beklemiyorum açıkçası özellikler buraya
boş gördükten sonra kolay fazla
heyecanlandırıyor Ben de etme on sınıfı
sizi böyle görünce aklıma bir
arkadaşının metroda Geçen hafta bir
konuşmamız geliyor etrafınızda
bakıyorduk öbür Duygu Bana da anda bu
kadar fazla insanın kendi hayatımı
geçtiğinde da o anda gelmişti ama şu
anda görünce anlıyorum ki
benim gördüğüm kadarıyla yoksunuz Şu
anda benim hayatımda sadece figüran
olmamıza rağmen hepinizin kendi
hayatları başladı bu hayatta beraber
gelen noktaları var bende kendine ait
bir hayatını kız ve benim de kızma
notaların var Bugün size
son32.com anlatacağım ben 2019 mezunuyum
mezun oldum 2019'a
Ben burada Herkesin Bildiğini
düşünüyorum ilk açımız bu sınav sayısal
bölümü Ben çıktığımız yani sınava
Girdikten de çıktıktan sonra bir anda
anlamaya başladım Çünkü birincisi
üzerinden çok büyük Kalmıştı bir sene
boyunca bir şey çalıştığımız görmek ve
onu bittiğine sahip olmak rahatlatıcı ve
çok hafif bir duygu Çünkü kursa gittiğim
dershaneye gittim ders aldığım soruyor
soru çözdüm arasam yalvardığım bunu
Anlamadığın yerleri Almasınlar diye
gitmişler ikinci olarak da sonuna kadar
diye geçirdiğimi düşünüyorum ben bundan
sonraki bir ay boyunca onlar açıklanana
kadar almaya devam ettim Hatta şöyle
birşey oldu kitapçıkları alıp okula
geldim 32 noktaya işletim ve aşağı
yukarı yönetimi puanları bil diye o
kendi ağladım diye işlenmesi bittikten
sonra da ağladım O bir ay boyunca
ağladım be almaya çıtır aldım Çünkü okul
sadece benim için akademik açıdan
başladım olabilir O değilde ayvanda
özgür olmak istiyordum sesini
duyurabilmek istiyordum farklı Sosyal
aktivitelere katılmak istiyordum yani
sonuç olarak benim alalım olmalıydı
orası ben bu bir aylık süreç boyunca her
zaman ağladım Daha sonrasında puanlar
açıklandı ve bir bakalım anlattım aldım
poslu gözlüm hiç
Daha sonrasında puanlar açıklandı ve
benim her zaman istediğin zaten Lütfen
siz okula gelebilmek ne öğrenebilmek
için aramayı seviyorum farklı kültürler
görmek hoşuma gidiyor ve bu dili de
zorla bize düşündüm çünkü bu farklı bir
kültürü var Ben
geldiğim zaman bu karar verdim zaman
bana ailem de dahil olmak üzere çıktı
çünkü yurt dışına gitmek sattılar burada
kullanmak istemeyenler ama ben dedi
herkesin dediğini umursamadan buraya
geldim Burada okumaya başladım ben
hayatımda işte çok tatlı öğrendim
sıfırdan bir öğrendim sana da derse
girdim ve Gerçekten bu kadar başarılı
olabileceğini düşünmüştüm tatlım okulda
çeşitli aktiviteler katıldım Hayatımda
ilk defa yazılarımı geliştirecek fırsatı
buldum kendimi Yani hemen
burada yazı yazmaya başladım Yani
aslında hayatım benim için bayağı iyi
geldi bana ve burada bu konuşmayı
sizinle yapabiliriz Daha sonrasında Bu
başarının da aslında
olmadığını görmüş oldum
Bütün olduğunu görmüş olduk Bu da bir
anda Çünkü bu kadar başarısız olmaktan
bu kadar Hata yapmaktan korkan ben Bu
yazı yazmaya başladıktan sonra buraya
geldikten sonra kendimi bulduktan sonra
bir şekilde başarı kaldı Tamam oturdu Bu
benim de yandı
ve ikimiz de yüksek oranlarla başladı
Eminem
hepimizin hayatında çok önemli Bir dönüm
noktasıydı çünkü en son benim öyleydi
yani Eve kapandık hiçbir şey yapamadık
makyaj taktık ve
midemi bulandırıyor artık ve gerçekten
büyük bir paraları başlangıcıydı aynı
zamanda tam okula geldim yeni bir okul
alışıyorum aradı Annem sanıyorum dili
öğreniyorum arkadaşa diyorum derken
birden bunu kullanmadım sahibi Hayat
başladığımız için
ben bu süreçte büyük paranoya gördüm
herkese göz Anladım kendim vardı bu
parmağına da aslında mesela Market
poşetleri geliyor kapıya kadar o Market
poşetleri orada 13 saat bekliyoruz Ondan
sonra mutfağa getirdi onlar yıkanıyordu
Ondan sonra balkona gidiyordu ve O
parçada bekliyoruz da bu
kauçuk orta yerine Daha sonrasında çok
acımasız bir bıraktı benim babam son bir
yıldır 50 başında o doğum günü artık da
üzerine 56 olacaktı aynı zamanda Zehra
kendisi falan kullanmayı seviyorum çünkü
hiç zahmetle bırakmadı son nefese kadar
insanlara yardım etmeye devam etti
ya Baba filmi insanlar için çok farklı
farklı şeyler ifade ediyor Benim için
olur insan demektir varlığından şüphe
etmediğini olacağını bildiğin
buydu varlığından emin olduğum tüm
ağırlığıyla hayatımda olacağını bildiğin
Burada şunu söylemek istiyorum buraya
çıkmadan önce çok düşündüm bunu anlatsam
diye akıllı noktaları hayatınızda zaten
bir sürü olacak Bir sürü oldu ve bu k.ma
anlatmak da Hem bana hem de size ye
farklı bakış açısını görmeye yardım
edeceğini düşünüyorum Bu kırılmaktan
daha sonra ayakta maması Dünya Güneş'in
etrafında bir tur attı Dört Mevsim
yaşandı 52 hafta bitti Ben haftanın beş
günü okula geldim Ve böylece hayatım
gibi oyası Tamam oldu bu ve hayat devam
ederken Aslında bu hem çok gerçek hem
çok rahatlatıcı hem de çok sinir bozucu
bir şey rahatlatıcı Çünkü hayat devam
ettim ve her şey yolundaydı ama aynı
zamanda sinir bozuyor Çünkü ayakta
kalmasını Ben onu hiç değildi
Ben bu konuşmayı hazırlarken açıkçası
şunu çok düşündüm bölüm İçinizde çok
büyük bir boşluk bırakıyor
yani böyle bir boşluk ki bu dolduracağız
biliyorsunuz Ben de zaten dolduracağım
biliyorum doldurmaya
bıraktın mı
var bunun üzerine hayat Tamam yaptı ve
ben bu konuşmayı yapmak için annemle
konuştum çünkü Fark ettim de onun önüne
dahil olma daha iyi bir şey
hatırlamıyorum
annemin yanına gittim onu anlattım
ısırmaya başladım ve bana şöyle küçük
bir olayı anlattı balonların haber verdi
gün sabah bana bunu söyledikten sonra
ben de tamam deyip Daha sonrasında
arkasında
ama bu birazcık trajikomik ve Evet o
zekatını Ama şunu sordu Daha sonrasında
bana Ben seni kırmıyorum bu
cevabı hayır bu beni kırmıyor bu beni
sevmiyor Çünkü
ben zaten zamanda kıldığım için şu anda
buradayım ses istemiyorsa gözlerinde
olmuyorsa heyecanlanıyorsan beni
Ağlıyorsam Sizin karşınızda bu hiç
olmadığından değil oldu Tabii ki Tabii
ki ağladım ama yine de buraya geldim
Çünkü
benim için geride kaldı
de buluşmak saçma unutmak Oo gereksiz
ama unutmuyorsun zaten alışıyorsunuz
unsuz oldu ulaşıyorsunuz Ben bugün
buraya geldi
var yani işe gideriz birincisi
duygularınız ağlayan kızın mutlu olun
bağırın Ne yapıyorsunuz ama o da göre
tanıyın Çünkü o duyguları kalmadan
onları onlarda başlatmayı bilemezsiniz
ölümün önüne başlatmanın tekniği oluyor
önüne başlatalım birden fazla bu bunun
için tekrar alınarak bu süreç atlamıyor
onu geçmek zorundasınız ve bunu yapmak
için
hepinize zaman
ve bu bavul öldürdün Annem saçlarımı
oluşuyordu ve bir gün sana bir anda bana
söyledi
içinde Siz bugün 41 mu yandı nokta ki
köprü boyunca her gün bir tane soracak
ve en sonunda bir tanesi kalacak O da
sonsuza kadar seninle olacak haklıydı
Gerçekten içindeki yangın yeri birden
bire kıvılcım olmuştu Bizde öyle
dediğime bakmayın uzunluğu yavaştı ama
dönüştü bu kırıldıysa son bölüm ama
zamanda güveni Çünkü o yangın yerine
okula dönüşebilecek olan tek şey daha
şimdi şöyle bir şey var kadar güçlü
olmaktan bahsettim o kadar ölümden
bahsettim burada yapmış şunu anlatmak
için çıktım biranın bir insanın hayatını
ne kadar değiştirebilecek benim hayatıma
boyu Kağıt çok gönderdi birincisiyle
başarının tek bir şey olmadığını anladım
ikincisi ile ise güçlü olmanın bir bütün
olduğunu anladım yani size sonuç güçlü
yapmıyor
ne yapıyor beni o süreç yaptı
bağladım düştüm kalktım Çok özledim
uçtum bunu hepsini tekrar yaptım çünkü o
süreç bunu gerektiriyordu ve ben böyle
bir şey oldum öyle bir şey olduğunu
düşündüm En azından bugün Sizin
karşınızda konuşma yapacak gücü O evet
de böyle mi
[Alkış]